اليسا واصاله طبعا نجمتين كبار ممكن نقول
انه احد القواسم المشتركه بينهم انهم
يعبروا عن رايهم وجهات نظرهم باي موضوع
وبكل اريحيه وما بيفرق معهم سواء كانت
سياسيه اجتماعيه يعني ايا كان والساعات
الماضيه النجمتين كانوا وسط جدل بيتعلق
بملف اللاجئين في لبنان اليسا معروفه من
زمان مننا بتاييد عوده اللاجئين لبلادهم
وبالتزامن مع التوتر الايام الماضيه
واطلاق عشرات الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان على
اسرائيل وقالت اسرائيل انه مجموعات
فلسطينيه وراء هذا الاطلاق وسط كل هذا
اعاده اليس التاكيد على موقفها وهذا الشيء
عملته عبر اعاده تغريد كثير تغريدات بتدعو
لعوده اللاجئين لبلادهم وبعض هذه
التغريدات لصحفيين اللبنانيين كبار ولمن
رجع الكلام عن ارائها هذه وطلعت اصوات
تايد واصوات تنتقد مثل العاده ردت اليسا
بتغريده مباشره وقالت فيها ان هي بتحب
وطنها ومصلحتها يعني ما بحياتها قللت من
احترام
شعب وخاصه شعب عربي بتنتمي له وانما
بتعتقد انه في اي اهانه لمن تطلب عوده
مواطنين لبلادهم لانه وطن الانسان كرامته
ومن بعدها بساعات رواد تويتر شافوا تغريده
لاصاله كمان عن نفس الموضوع وبنقول فيها
اصاله بانه كلنا في الارض لاجئين وما حد
بيملك اي مكان في اي ارض كلنا زوار مهما
طالت زيارتنا وانه بدنا نرحم بعد لانه ما
في شيء بيرحمنا الدنيا صعبه وظروف الناس
صعبه وقالت ما احد حط فوق راسه خيمه واللي
اليوم متاح بكره ما نعرف لو ممكن وكفايه
انه نتجزا وخلاص صار وقت ولو لمره واحده
انه نتوحد كتار شافوا في تغريده اصاله هذه
يرد على اليسا ونزلت على العناوين انه
بتقول انه اصاله تهاجم اليسارا وان قال
خلاص ولعت حرب بارده بين اليسا واصاله
ويمكن عشان كده رجعت غردت اصاله بعدها
ووضحت وقالت الاختلاف في الاراء ما يعني
انه بنزعل من بعض اليسا حبيبتي
وارد بين الاصحاب الخلاف بالاراء وحتى
المبادئ اليسا ما ردت اي رد مباشر ولا
ذكرت اسم اصاله ابدا لكنها غرضت كلام غير
مباشره وقالت انه الحقيقه غريبه الناس
كثير كيف الانسان بيلغي كل شيء حلو وبيركز
على شيء اصلا فاهمه غلط على العموم مش
مشكلتي في ناس شافت الكلام اصاله او عفوا
الكلام اصاله هي اللي مقصوده فيه والناس
قالت لا هي بتتكلم عموما وعموما من ساعات
غرضت اصاله كمان تغريده جديده كتبت فيها
انه احلى بلد في العالم هو لبنان
[موسيقى]